you're watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the journalists and author rachel
shabby and the telegraphs leader writer
tim stanley so there they are hello to
you both let's have a look what's on the
front pages
the observer describes the jubilee
festivities as a long weekend and a
carnival of memory the telegraph
highlights a comedy sketch shown during
tonight's special concert in which the
queen co-starred with paddington bear
the times calls the event the party of a
lifetime for the world's grandmother the
express quotes prince charles's speech
thank you for being there for us mommy
the sunday people pictures the guitarist
brian may above the headline thriller
queen
sister paper the sunday mirror has a
near identical front page with the
splash rock and roll
while scotland's sunday national uses
the occasion to argue against the
monarchy and in favor of a second
independence referendum
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you see on your screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us
and i was saying we're joined tonight by
rachel and tim there they are good
evening to you both quite a night um i'd
just like to get your thoughts on that
uh concert rachel were you watching
um i watched for about five minutes and
then i hit my limit i'm afraid
rachel i knew i just knew you were gonna
say something
i'm that predictable i know
tim what did you think
rachel probably didn't care for the
politics i didn't care for the music
oh gosh you guys
it was a mixed bag it was there was
stuff that was uh very good
it was undeniably a very very well put
together choreographed show it was a mix
of the old and the new
and every generation there was something
in it for you it was like a box of
quality streets so for my generation
jonathan jason donovan turning up to
seeing any dream we'll do
that that made the evening uh as for the
rest of it there were some love numbers
that was the key moment of the evening
for you was it so you're a musical
theater fan or a jason jonathan fan
oh either either i just it's just it's
just so it's so great to see him back uh
performing really i'm not not that big a
fan it was it was
it was a spectacular show there's
there's no disguise behind that but it's
not everyone's taste no no that's true
that's true it was a spectacular show
let's talk um generally about this whole
bank holiday weekend the platinum
jubilee rachel the observer calling it a
carnival of memory a long weekend in a
carnival of memory
yeah look you know i think that's
probably true for a lot of people you
know i'm sure a lot of people up and
down the country as the observer and
other newspapers report
did experience it as that but i think
it's also just as important to say that
a lot of people just didn't that's the
thing about britain we're not you you're
not sort of unified in this glory fest
for the royal family it's just not the
reality we can tell that
because of the flags and the bunting
that are ubiquitous in some kind parts
of the country and not so much in other
parts of the country we can tell that
from polling we know that scotland is
kind of a bit indifferent we know that
younger people are
pretty much not that into it and are of
the view that the royal family is not
going to be the royal family for that
much longer
of course people who were lucky enough
to have those extra two days off are
delighted at that um of course it's nice
to have a break but i i think we do need
to be
a little bit more um
nuanced and inclusive in our appraisal
of this weekend it wasn't
wall-to-wall flag waving from
every member
of the british population yeah no that's
true and we do have to remember that tim
what do you think i mean a lot of people
looking at the festivities and thinking
well my energy bill is still going to go
up and i've got to pay my council tax at
the end of this month
oh what a miserable way to approach life
that's ridiculous this is possibly a
reality for many
do they sorry do they not do they skip
someone's wedding or someone's
christening because the rest of their
life is miserable so they're not going
to partake in any kind of fun i mean
that's a very odd approach towards life
look i did i'll discuss republics versus
monarchies later what i found
interesting about the guardians piece uh
is that it sort of went there and
there's almost a journalistic consensus
that you don't do this which is you
discuss the fact that the question the
observer tim i just want to uh bring it
up
yeah thank you
you you discuss the fact that the queen
is very very old and the writer um
the writer tim adams described this
weekend as a long goodbye which is an
interesting take on what i've not seen
elsewhere and and he is right
there were some events that the queen
was physically too frail to attend
um which
he links that back to her appearance
alone at prince philip's funeral
we have to get used to the idea that the
queen is winding down that this is the
article quotes d khan a 24 7 job for a
96 year old lady and whilst this weekend
was all about celebrating queen
elizabeth ii what was striking was the
prominent role played by prince charles
and by the rest of the family and that's
what the queen's life for the last
couple of decades has really been
gearing towards protecting the
institution and making sure that there
are there are people who understand it
and care for it and ready to take it
over when she goes so although the
attack is a little controversial and
something journalists don't often do i
think they're quite right to draw our
attention to this being a jubilee in
which there was a sense of a torch being
handed on
rachel let's talk about some of you
brought up scotland and their view of
this how is the national tackling it
well i mean the national is pointing out
what you know tim has
described as miserableism but you you
could just say is it's just the reality
of life for many people in the uk at the
moment it is
uh the fact that you know life is pretty
tough at the moment there's a lot of
anxiety around people having to make
brutal decisions
about how to prioritize money that just
isn't going far enough having to choose
between putting food on the table or
heating the home
this is the reality for people who are
in work as well we have an economy that
isn't working and so
it is jarring to have at this precise
time this four day festival
of actually an institution that probably
does the most to cement
a brutal inequality in britain than
anything else it entrenches the class
system the deference the idea that you
know privilege trumps everything else
um that is one of the things that what
about breaking it down and i'm going to
jump in
i'm going to jump in what about breaking
it down to a local level and saying
listen we've had a tough two years
i want to show tim actually because tim
has got his his um head in his hands
they said we've had a tough two years
and we're all going to get together as
communities regardless of what we think
of the monarchy and just
have a bit of a celebration for four
days rachel
well that's fine
and i'm sure lots of people did that
what isn't fine is pretending that that
is the reality for most of the country
and trying to enforce the idea
as our front pages are doing this
weekend that that is the case it's just
not it's like this huge
juggernaut of publicity and branding and
it's just not a reality for many people
in this country okay we've gotta we've
got a wrap there tim tim i know you want
to talk about this we'll talk about it
after the break
because coming up
we'll talk about this but we'll also
turn our attention to politics and a
poll that could be troubling reading for
the tories ahead of the wakefield via
election
[Music]
with me now rachel shabby and tim
stanley there they are back okay tim
over to you i did promise um just give
your reaction to rachel saying that you
listen the platinum jubilee celebrations
they just don't resonate with everyone
well of course they don't but they do
resonate with the vast majority the
turnout of the jubilee i think
demonstrates that polls consistently
show the monarchy is incredibly popular
it usually polls around 69 to about 75
as for the charge that the monarchy is
inappropriate in a time of poverty well
it does a huge amount for charity and it
promotes public service as for the
suggestion that it is arcane if you were
watching the jubilee concert it was a
celebration of diversity and equality
and also um prince william gave a five
minute speech about how important it is
to save the environment i think moaning
about the monarchy during the jubilee is
like moaning about family during
christmas okay maybe maybe it's not for
you but most people are just getting on
with it and enjoying it and if you don't
like it just turn off the tv and don't
watch it which is what i have to do
every time there's a football world cup
on
we won't get into football we simply
cannot get into football
let's turn to politics oh there's a
happy
happy subject
um okay rachel uh the times and they are
talking about the wakefield by-election
and saying that the tories are on course
for defeat there just talk us through
that one
yes so the times is reporting that um
[Music]
labor has a 20-point lead
in this seat there's a by-election
coming up in wakefield which uh you
remember the tories took from um labor
in a shock
uh
result that was part of the crumbling of
the red wall in that 2019 election for
labor
now this is thought to be worrying a lot
of conservatives understandably they
were thinking well maybe the red wolf
so-called ray walked redwall is okay
after the recent local election results
showed that
labour were not making
that many inroads in that area
and so this has come as a bit of a
surprise and it comes at the same time
that there's thought to be some 67
letters calling for a
no-confidence vote
and the prime minister um next week far
exceeding that the threshold required to
trigger that and also some 190 mps uh
um
thought to be ready to vote against
boris johnson in such a vote which of
course is just 10 shy
of um toppling him and triggering a
leadership election
tim i i see you know do you think we're
going to see a leadership election well
do you think we're going to see a
no-confidence vote soon and what do you
think about this story in the times
about um that by-election in wakefield
uh my sense is that we are heading
towards some sort of confrontation the
the key thing about the by-elections is
that one is a classic blue wall seat a
rural seat always votes tori the other
is a classic red wall seed wakefield
somewhere that the tories picked up and
that they need to win if they're going
to hold the next election
now the the argument for boris was
always that he could win the red wall
and no one else can if he loses it and
he loses it by a lot that's going to
shatter that reputation if he also loses
a blue wall seat at the same time then
what that will tell people is that he's
also alienating the tory heartland so in
the event of an election they're not
only just going to lose up in the north
they're also going to lose down in the
south and that's what's going to really
panic people about johnson's leadership
the strongest argument behind him has
always been this
heir of boris is the only one who can
win us a proper majority but if he's
defeated heavily in those two
by-elections that i think will will
change a lot of hearts and minds in the
conservative party okay so rachel thanks